à l'arrivée du marathon du monde
mathématiques cette course dont la
particularité est d'accueillir une
infinité de coureurs la tortue de zénon
et d'escargots de garner voulurent
savoir lequel des deux avait été le plus
rapide mais n'ayant aucune idée du temps
qu'il aura fallu pour finir la course
la seule chose qu'ils avaient pour se
comparer et et leurs classements
respectifs
le classement de la tortue était au
milliard 1 celui de l'escargot était
epsilon un bizarre qu'on classement non
pour comprendre ce classement et savoir
qui de la tortue ou de l'escargot est
arrivé avant il va nous falloir
comprendre ces nombres 10 38 me et oui
parce que si ni la tortue nine escargots
non un classement fini c'est tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont été
précédées d'un nombre infini de coureurs
et du coup leur classement qu'on appelle
aussi leur ordinale ne peut être qu'un
ordinale trans finir un ordinale au delà
de l'infini
comme toujours dans ce genre de course
ce sont les lapins qui ont été les plus
rapides
eux ce sont des pros surtout ceux du
club de phibro qui d'ailleurs recense
tous les lapins de son club avec des
numéros philly sans surprise tous et a
peint son arrivée avant tout le monde
dans l'ordre de leur numéro au final le
lapin 0 de fibois le classement 0 le
lapin et le classement 1
et ainsi de suite le premier cours après
les lapins de fib aura forcément un
ordinale trans fini en fait il aura le
meilleur des classements trans fini qui
est le plus petit ordinale trans fini
quand l'appel
omega il se trouve que le oméga iem
coureur est une honte ils eurent qui
appartient à un club si inspiré par le
club de phibro qui l'a choisi d'être
appelé fibo 1 comme le club fribault le
club fribault un possède une infinité de
coureurs tous numérotés et d'ailleurs ce
sont tous des antilopes et ils sont tous
arrivés après le club si beau mais avant
n'importe quel autre coureur et quels
sont les classements de ses couleurs
trans finie et bien l'antilope qui vient
juste après antilopes oméga alors à un
ordinateur le mans oméga plus un ça
paraît simplement fait l'addition des
ordis notre ans fini est quelque chose
d'assez subtile par exemple qu'est-ce
que d'après vous un puceau médias ce que
ça la même chose que omega +1
qu'en pensez vous
pour comprendre l'addition il faut bien
comprendre que les ordis nous ne
mesurent pas les tailles des infinis et
l'ordre dans lequel les choses arrive
quand on fait aux médias +1 ou considère
deux ensemble chacun des saisons semble
va être l'ensemble des ordinands avant
aux médias et avant un donc le premier
section avant mes gars c'est tous les
nombres fini et le second se sont tous
les ordis nos avants 1
et ça il n'ya que l'ordinateur 0 oméga
+1 est alors l'ordinateur un coureur qui
voit arriver avant lui les coureurs tout
premier ensemble puis celui du deuxième
ensemble et ça ça correspond exactement
à ce que voit l'antilope 1-2 fibo 1 du
cool ordinale de l'antilope 1-2 fibo un
va être oméga plus un qui va être
strictement plus grand que l'original de
l'antilope 02 fibo un qui est égal au
médias
mais quand on fait un puceau médias on
inverse l'ordre des deux ensembles qu'on
avait considéré d'abord le coureur avant
l'ordination puis l'infinité de cours
avant omega sauf que là on voit qu'on
peut aisément attribuer un ordinaire
fini à tous les coureurs du coup lors
dina la tribu et à 1 court arrivant
après tout ça est le premier ordinale
transmis au méga pas où mais y'a plus en
l'addition des ordis notre ans finit
l'ennemi commutative ni injected comme
vous l'imaginez les autres antilopes de
fibres à vous ensuite à voir les
classements aux médias +1 aux médias
plus d'oméga 3 et ainsi de suite
mais maintenant un cheval arrive après
tout les antilopes de fibres qu'elle va
être l'ordinateur de ce cheval ouais
c'est ça oui oui vous l'avez oui c'est
ça oméga plus qu'aux médias en effet le
cheval voir arriver une infinité de
lapin numérotées puis une infinité
d'antilopes numérotées le cheval a bien
le classement qui suit ces deux
ensembles qui chacun précède un ordinale
aux médias
l'ordinateur cheval est on bien ordinale
oméga plus oméga et oméga puis sa mégane
envie de dire que c'est deux fois oméga
à moins que ce ne soit au méga watts 2
qu'est ce que peut bien vouloir dire la
multiplication d ordinaire mais gare x 2
correspond à dire qu'on a deux groupes
de coureurs chaque groupe étant
numérotée avec les ordinaux qui précède
oméga et les deux groupes arrivant à
l'un après l'autre un coureur arrivant
après ses deux gros porc alors
l'ordinateur ou méga x 2 dont on peut
remarquer qu'il est égal à vous mes gars
plus oméga mais à linverse deux fois
méga correspond à une infinité de
coureurs où chaque groupe est une paire
de deux coureurs
lorsque ses pairs de coureurs arrivent
successivement on voit que l'on peut
attribuer un ordinale fini à l'arrivée à
tous les coureurs puisque aucun de ses
coureurs n'arrive après une infinité de
coureurs si bien que celui qui arrivera
après tous ces coureurs orale ordinale
deux fois au méga dont on peut remarquer
qu'il va être le premier ordinale
transmis ni oméga pas oméga x 2 comme
l'addition la multiplication n'est ni
commutative ni injected oui c'est super
bizarre mais bref avant sont comme vous
l'imaginez on peut considérer qu'il ya
une infinité de chevaux dans le club de
fibres depuis un club de fibres 3 avec
aussi une infinité numérotées de
taureaux et puis fibo 4 et ainsi de
suite
on voit que le jm coureurs du club fibo
y peut être localisé par son ordinale
oméga y plus j et on peut même aller
plus loin se demander qu'est ce qu'il ya
après tous les animaux de tous ces clubs
bibeau principe du club de fibo que l'on
retrouve dans la vie de natty est repris
dans la ville voisine nati un puits dans
ati 2 et ainsi de suite
si bien que dans chaque nachi cas on
trouve une infinité de clubs fibo il
chacun contenant une infinité de
coureurs j alors il se trouve que tout
coureur de nha ky 2 est plus long que
tout coureur de natty 1 tout comme tout
coureur de nachi 3 et plus long que tout
coureur de 22 et ainsi de suite
du coup le classement 12e coureurs du
club vib au i de la ville nati cas sera
oméga carré fois cas plus oméga fois il
plus j'ai deux premiers coureurs
arrivant après tous ces coureurs des
vignes atika oural ordinale qui vient
après tout c'est trinôme du second degré
en oméga il aura alors dinallo méga cube
et on peut aller plus loin avec ce
principe d'une infinité de conteneurs
qui contiennent une infinité de
conteneurs qui contiennent une infinité
de contenu d'ailleurs david sur chance
et sonnantes donne l'exemple d'une
infinité de vaisseau qui contiennent une
infinité de bateaux qui contiennent une
infinité de plus qui contiennent une
infinité de personnes et bien un coureur
qui viendrait après cette infinité de
personnes de plus dans une infinité de
bateaux dans une infinité de vaisseau
aurait pour classement oméga puissance 4
puis généralement avec des conteneurs de
containers de conteneurs et ainsi de
suite
on peut former tous les ordis nos qui
sont des sommes finis de termes oméga
puissance n comme par exemple si on
huit types de conteneurs qui soutiennent
les uns après les autres on peut former
oméga puissent ensuite plus au méga puis
105 x 169 plus aux médias x 2 plus 4 un
coureur qui viendrait après tout les
coureurs qui sont dans des conteneurs de
containers de contador et bien ce
coureur là aura un ordinaire le plus
grand que tous les ordis nos comptes à
vues jusque là ce sera un ordinale qui
sera égal à oméga puissance au mes gars
autrement dit pour ceux qui connaissent
les polynôme oméga puissance oméga elle
ordinale qui vient après tout les
polynôme ans aux médias à coefficient
qui sont des anti naturel mais on peut
aller encore plus loin et penser à des
espèces de super pauline oméga puissance
oméga puissance oméga et l'ordinaire qui
vient après les ordis nos qui s'écrivent
comme des sommes finis de termes de la
forme oméga puissance un polynôme en
oméga on peut appeler ces termes qui
viennent avant aux médias puissance au
milieu puissant somme il ya des supers
polynôme de niveau 1
on peut alors construire des supers
polynôme de niveau 2 ans proxy d'hérens
toutes les sommes finis de oméga
puissance un super pays nomme deux
niveaux en oméga c'est super plénum de
niveau 2 sera suivi par an méga
puissance coup média puissant ce média a
appuyé son méga et on peut continuer
ainsi considérant ensuite les super
poids énorme de niveau 3 qui sont des
sommes finis de oméga puissance un super
pays normes de niveau 2 les ordinaux qui
peuvent s'obtenir avec une combinaison
fini d'addition de multiplication et
d'exposants ciation de oméga ou de
termes finis sont les ordinands qui
peuvent s'écrire sous la forme normale
de kantor et y en a beaucoup
une affinité mais ça ne nous empêche pas
d'imaginer un ordinale qui vient après
tout les ordinaux en forme normale de
canfor 7 ordinale qui transcende des
opérations que soit l'addition la
multiplication et l'ex prononciation des
ordinaux va devoir être plus grand que
tous les oméga puissance aux médias
puissance aux médias puissants médias et
ainsi de suite avec une pile fini d
oméga et ça ça va correspondre à steve
médias puissance au melia puissance
formula mais avec un nombre infini de
aux médias dans la pile est bien cette
ordinale monstrueux qui ne peut être
écrit en fonction de vos médias que si
l'on utilise trois petits points
c'est ce que l'on appelle epsilon 0
epsilon 0 étrangement en fait énormément
d'applications dans la théorie des
validité des preuves mathématiques donc
les nombres transmis qui sont au-delà de
l'infini nous permettre de comprendre
les méta mathématiques
c'est à dire des trucs qui sont au-delà
des mathématiques il carrément en
particulier le théorème de gan scène
montre que l'on peut prouver la validité
des preuves de l'arithmétique de p and o
à partir d'une récurrence non pas comme
celles que vous voyez à l'école qui
s'applique ou entiers naturels uniques
en mai d'une récurrence dit trans fini
qui s'applique au delà des nombres
entiers naturels qui s'applique jusqu'au
ordinaux est en fait il suffit que cette
récurrence trans fini s'applique à tous
les ordis nos jusqu'à épsiode 0 joue la
corde c'est super bizarre comme théorème
puisque l'on ne parle pas d'objets
mathématiques mais des preuves
mathématiques
en fait on pourrait l'appeler mais
malgré tous nos efforts on en n'est
toujours pas arrivé aux ordis nos doigts
est tortueux et de l'escargot comment
peut-on accélérer notre croissance
d'ordino on pourrait penser que omega
puissance épsiode 0 va nous amener loin
mais ypsilon 0 c'est déjà une grosse
pile infinie d'exportation de oméga-6
bien aux médias puissance ips l'audience
ça va être un méga puissance oméga
puissants solides appuis sont soumis les
productions sont milliards et donc tout
ça ça va être
epsilon 0 ce qui est assez incroyable
epsilon 0 est si grand que omega
puissance epsilon 0 est égal à epsilon 0
mais on peut aller plus loin et par
exemple construire épisode zéro
puissance épsiode 0 pour alicia 0
puissance et piano 0 puissance m50 et
puis même faire une pile de plus en plus
longue des epsilon 0 et bien une pile
infinie deux et puis ça nous
ça correspond à un ordinale que l'on ne
peut pas écrire en fonction de l'epsilon
0 avec uniquement des multiplications
des additions et des expos nantiat sion
cette ordinale que l'on ne peut exclure
en fonction des pylônes 0 que si on
utilise trois petits points
on l'appelle epsilon 1 c'est le
classement de notre escargots on a enfin
compris le classement de notre escarment
mai puis des deux hommes égard le
classement notre tortue est bien pour le
comprendre il va nous falloir une façon
d'aller bien plus vite que toutes les
méthodes d'addition multiplication
exponentielle à sion ou limite
d'exploitation avec trois petits points
que l'on a vu jusque là parce que aucune
de ces méthodes ne nous permet d'arriver
jusqu'à 1 milliard l'astuce pour
vraiment bondir consiste à cros marqué
une propriété commune à tous les ordis
nos qu'on a défini jusque là tous les
ordis nos on a vu son dénombrable et oui
au final il est en fait autant de façons
d'écrire des superbes poulies nommant
epsilon 1 et en oméga voir en epsilon
qu'à voir des trucs comme epsilon
indices ou liga voire même des épisodes
indices epsilon 0 ou encore des épisodes
indices actions et indices
epsilon un tout c'est hors des eaux sont
énormes et on peut l'imaginer énormément
de combinaisons d'entre eux mais le
nombre de toutes ces combinaisons n'est
pas plus grand que le nombre de lapins
du club fibo tous ces ensembles d'ordino
sont tous dénombrable pour comprendre ce
concept de dénombre habilité il faut
oublier que l'on cherche à considérer
l'ordre dans lequel arrivent les choses
aient utilisé des astuces comme celle
dont vous parlez angie et david sur son
étonnante pour mesurer les tailles d
ensemble qu'on appelle des cardinaux
bref pour faire un énorme bond nous
suffit de considérer le premier à
arriver après un nombre un des nombreux
à bhl de coureurs
cette ordinale est le plus petit des
ordinaux indénombrables et on l'appelle
au milliard mais sommet lien c'est notre
tortue qui vient donc bien bien bien
après l'escargot
ceci dit il faut relativiser dans cette
course du monde mathématiques et il y en
a en fait infiniment plus qu'ils sont
sains et bien après notre tortue
là les enfants on a parlé les
infinitésimaux étendue dx
ennis et pierre magnus nous demandent
pourquoi est ce que on retrouve ceux des
x dans des notations mathématiques par
décret d'érection dx où on fait
l'intégrale de fgx est raide lightning
se demandent notamment si cette
intégrale de paix xtx correspond à
ajouter un continuum infinie d'infinité
idées et la réponse de l'analyse
standard c'est que non pas du tout tout
cela ne s'agit uniquement que de
notation qui sont en fait des artefacts
du passé de la pensée de la glisse qui
lui interprété tout ça en termes
d'infinité zinou mais les mathématiques
modernes tout cas les mathématiques
standard il interprète tout ça pas du
tout comme des infinitésimaux puisqu'il
n'existe pas d'infinité immo dans les
mathématiques s'attendent à ce site et
on reparlera de l'intégrale puisqu'il
s'agit d'un concept qui a beaucoup
évolué et qui conduit notamment à
travers d'un tegra 2 lebègue a des trucs
un peu ultra futur one de chailly se
pose la question des différentiels en
effet en mathématiques standard on a un
objet mathématique que l'on appelle des
f et qu'on appelle une différentiel medf
faut faire gaffe ce n'est pas un
infinitésimale c'est une différentiel
c'est une approximation linéaire elle
est liée à l'idée de différentiel dans
la mesure où elle correspond à la
description locales lorsqu'on zoome
lorsqu'on regarde très très près donc
lorsqu'on regarde et toute petite
échelle par exemple si on prend un
cercle et que l'on zoome sur une partie
du cercle cadet très petite échelle le
cercle ressemble à ce moment là a un
truc tout droit une droite est bien là
différentiel permet de décrire cette
droite travers ce qu'on appelle une
application linéaire enfin la mer fois
que j'avais demandé de spam et antoine
de l'aide parce qu'il avait défini une
solution complètement astucieuse sans
explication est différente de celle de
ramanujan au point que des mets sont
numérotées et grâce à du spam en tonnes
de l'aig
pas répondu mais par contre baptiste
goujaud a donné des explications qui
permettent de retrouver ce résultat les
explications sont assez durs à
comprendre donc je vais pas pouvoir les
expliquer en tout cas pas en une minute
juste là mais je peux vous donner
quelques idées de cette preuve
en gros l'idée c'est que l'équation de
ramon joueurs donc on peut l'écrire
deuxième plus invoquer harry moins deux
fois deuxième quart et est égal à 1
alors pour simplifier notation je vais
remplacer le 2ème plus un paris x et le
deuxième par y
c'est une bonne x carré - 2 y carré est
égal à 1
et là on peut réécrire sa comme étant xk
rémois y x racine carrée de deux au
carré est égal à 1 et là on reconnaît
identités remarquables
donc on peut factoriser et on obtient x
plus y racine carrée de 2 x x - y pourra
s'inspirer de 2 est égale 1-1 et donc si
on appelle z le premier facteur et z bar
le deuxième facteur qui une sorte de
conjuguer ainsi à basr à 5-2 j'avais
issa serait le conjuguer complexe là en
fait c'est le conjuguer non pas dans les
complexes mais ce qu'on appelle plus
crochet racine carrée de 2 en fait les
deux bonnes raisons pour appeler ça
raconte j'ai essayé à la théorie de
galois peut pas rentrer dans les détails
en gros ce qui nous importe c'est de
trouver un z qui s'écrit donc x plus y
racine carrée de deux tels que z à son
inverse qui est lui aussi quelque chose
qui est de la forme x plus y racine
carrée de deux et ça serait bien de la
dire que x plus y a six cars 2 doit être
inversible dans ce que l'on appelle la
nauze aide crochet racine carrée de ça
si j'utilise des termes un peu plus
technique pour dire exactement ce que je
viens de dire alors il ya pas mal façons
de façon de déterminer l'ensemble des
inversible dans un crochet racing cars 2
ce que propose baptiste google que je
trouve vraiment cool c'est de prendre le
logarithme de cette égalité zz bas est
égal à 1 obtient locke de zz bar est
égal à loeb 2 1 et ça si vous connaissez
les log ça correspond à dire que locke
de z plus locke de z bar est égal à zéro
et on peut faire un petit peu gars parce
qu'on n'a pas peur de prendre des lots
guitoune de dumb négatif mais à quelques
détails près on obtient exactement ça là
on voit que l'application acquis à z
associe locke deux aides et
l'ogre red bar va être une application
dont l'image va satisfaire toujours
cette équation donc si on trace l'homme
faisait des loques de z bar et bien tous
les inversible deux accrochés racine
carrée de deux vont forcément être le
long de la diagonale qui plus est si on
fait une multiplication de z par cette
prime
alors on obtient une addition entre les
points loeb de zz barre et luck 2 est
primé locke dz prix bas du coup
lorsqu'on fait une multiplication entre
deux inversible à dz prime ça correspond
à faire une addition vectorielle dans r2
dans le plan qui contient les images
loeb 2 et des legs de cette barre et
enfin un dernier argument à sortir c'est
le fait qu' on ne peut pas avoir des
points qui se rapprochent indéfiniment
près de zéro lorsque l'on considère les
inversible deux accrochés racing cars 2
est ce parce que les éléments de z
crochet racines car deux entités vont
elles sont assez discrets et ils peuvent
pas se rapprocher de 1 parce que si on
essaie de trouver des coefficients xp et
y pour que x plus y racine carrée de 2
se rapproche de 1 alors x - il gravait
krassimir de l'uva diverger à l'infini
du coup l'image des invincibles de z
crochet racine carrée de deux sont
forcément le long d'une droite mais de
façon discrète et ça ça implique qu'il
ya forcément un élément générateur de
tout cet ensemble est bien cet élément
générateur ça correspond à z égale un
plus racine carrée de deux bouquins puce
racine carrée de 2 et bien inversible
mais lorsque l'on fait un puce racine
carrée de deux fois son config et un
mois à saint pierre 2 2 on n'obtient pas
un comme on aurait voulu on ne tire
moins 1 donc on est presque là et du
coup on pourra avoir une solution du
problème il suffit de mettre ça au carré
un plus racine carrée de deux au carré
ça nous fait 3 + 2 racine carrée de 2 et
enfin on peut conclure en disant que le
groupe engendrée par un plus racine
carrée de deux dents être crochet racine
carrée de deux qui vont donc être les
trois plus racine carrée deux puissances
un nombre entier relatif eh bien ces
nombreux là vont être solution du
problème et les reste encore un peu de
calcul à gérer mais c'est juste du
calcul très simple à faire
et enfin on peut conclure avec la
solution d'antoine 2
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
dont claquée par les nombreux transferts
ordinaux il ya aussi des nombreux 38
cardinaux donc les rapidement par les
meilleurs plus de choses à dire vous
pouvez en savoir plus sur les cardinaux
avec la vidéo notamment de david sur son
segment
et puis aussi les vidéos de la ligie
donc là je n'ai mis que celle sur les
cardinaux mais on a aussi une qui
utilisent et ordinaux pour prouver ou en
tout cas pour parler du hydre de kirby
et paris la prochaine fois on va parler
de l'analyse de fourie qu une très
étrange et fresno insiste pas assez sûre
qu'elle pensait super bizarre
compétition et c'est ce que je vais
faire dans la prochaine vidéo le plus
généralement en fait là on va commencer
plusieurs vidéos qui vont vous montrer
que l'infini et super bizarre du sexe
n'y a pas mal fait deux vidéos qui
montrent les infinis super bizarre et
envoie on va continuer dans cette veine
dans les prochaines vidéos
l'objectif étant de convaincre il faut
absolument être super rigolo par bobby
et sa salle pour amener la fin de cette
série de vidéos sur l'infini qui va
parler beaucoup plus de l'axiomatique et
comment on fait pour s'assurer ou nous
que voit pas dire de la merde on
pardonne si vous avez aimé cet épisode
tant celle de laquelle le commentaire
est le partage et pensez à vous abonner
pas manquer lecture épisode merci aussi
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que
google prochain
et donc la conclusion de kantor c'est
que le cardinal des nombres réels classé
aussi l'infini mais c'est un afflux qui
est vraiment strictement plus gros que
celui dont on a parlé jusqu'ici c'est un
affront indénombrables une question qui
a longtemps perturbé les mathématiciens
en particulier quand tort est de savoir
s'il existe un infini intermédiaires qui
serait strictement plus grand que
l'infini des nombres entiers qui noté à
l'aise 0 est strictement plus petit que
celui de l'infini des nombres réels
noter deux puissances à lev 0